all right so hello everyone I'm Daniel
so right now I am currently a data
engineer slash research associate at my
lab which is the social decision
analytics lab at Virginia Tech it's part
of the bio complexity Institute
I am also currently a PhD student so I'm
trying to juggle working and fulfilling
in PhD and I totally understand why some
people will end up taking almost forever
trying to finish their PhD now and I
guess and my mom's there so like I'm
really like not making this easy for
myself so I guess my research question
is really leveraging government
administrative and open datasets for use
for public health mainly because I have
master's in public health and
epidemiology from Columbia University
yeah one of my performer professors is
also out here - dr. Melanie wall so
she's up there and I do work for a Jared
Lander and a lot of the I guess
experience from standing up here and
talking to people comes from the carpet
fries which is software and data
carpentry and I also have one data camp
class that's out and I'm recording one
on Sunday so there's that and so the
first thing I want to say is thanks so
this isn't the end of the talk banks
this is uh so this is a thanks to you
know the community - all you guys I'm
saying y'all because I'm currently at
school in the south and so so first of
all to our staff NYC it's pretty much
how I got my beginnings of how to learn
everything presenting and just just
constantly learning when I move down to
DC there was the data community DC thing
which was essentially when I went down
was how do I find what I had in New York
down in the DC / Virginia area and then
there's everyone else that I've met
along the way the PI data community site
PI has been really awesome they have
their conference every year and
Austin Texas and then last but not least
there's the carpentry which you know
those of you who don't know me I do a
lot of teaching and this is actually
where all of my teaching experience well
most of them come from and so yes this
this book this thing happened as you can
see there was like a tweet from 2016 so
there it was like a many a year endeavor
this is a picture that my sister drew
and I'm posting a tweet mainly because
like she doesn't own that picture
anymore so I I didn't know how the how
to post of rights of that picture but so
there we go
so this talk it's called doing data
science and you know this isn't our
conference and I wrote a python book and
I'm talking to you guys but it it really
comes down to like it's really not our
versus Python just like heavily wickham
said a few days ago it's really our and
python like the two communities can
totally live together you don't have to
pick one or the other but if you are
learning pick one that you're learning
you know that your friends are learning
so you can work together because over
time you will end up learning the other
language just by meeting everyone and
being in the community and if you didn't
know I mean at the end they were also
all friends right and so if you didn't
hear this news that was posted yesterday
you know of West McKinney and Hadley
Wickham can work together and start a
project together and we can all
definitely be friends alright and like
even more like if I have to say anything
it's more like the our community itself
like if you ever seen like the old Stack
Overflow comments and tirades or snark
between Derk and Hadley it's more like
what's wrong with our it within itself
then like this our Python thing going on
right so what what is data science so
this is a slide I sort of stole from the
Anaconda folks from the Python side and
you know they did it's a pretty good
graphic on like you know there's so many
buzzwords like what is it right and so
one of the ways you can break this down
is like you can break down tasks by what
are the actual tools you're you
so data science a to engineer I kind of
play both and like these days more or
less I'm working with datasets and
databases and getting everyone in my lab
the dataset that they need and then they
start the process of analyzing it and so
you know there's a bunch of overlap you
know we all do similar tasks so you know
this all ends up being like almost a
continue a continuum than like
individual roles and so last year if you
weren't here I essentially took all my
experience from running to day workshops
and compressing it into a 20 minute talk
and one of the things that I did or
talked about last year was about this
paper about structuring your projects
and this is a paper by William Noble and
in this paper he does he has this figure
which is you know how to structure your
your arm projects right you know it's
very easy when you just start off that
all of your files and scripts and output
all end up in one folder and then you
end up with this problem where you have
100 files and you can't find anything
right and so he's saying that hey like
here's an academic paper so maybe people
start doing in in academia how to
structure your projects and once you
have like a folder structure you can
start scripting it so you know there's
this reproducible science curriculum
that has a script I wrote a script and
it's really like a bash script that
creates some files and dumps a readme or
a get keep file so you can check it into
version control systems and if you
remember either Jerez talked last year a
year before you can also just write all
this in are rightly you don't even have
to leave our studio to make this happen
and then so Greg Wilson which is one of
the co-founders it from software
carpentry he him and a whole bunch of
the software carpentry team they all
wrote a paper in 2014 about best
practices for scientific computing and
then they try to update it and talk to
that 17 for like what's good enough
but like what ended up happening they
really just talked about like hey right
functions right loops if your copy and
pasting something like 50 times to run
something 50 times you're probably doing
it wrong you know plan for mistakes
start checking other people's code if
possible version control collaborate and
the good enough paper really just sort
of like shows you a little bit more
about how and I'm talking to you about
this mainly because my lab we run a
summer program called data science for
the public good and essentially what
happens every summer is like there's
around fifteen undergraduate students
who don't know anything about our a lot
of them never seen this before and then
five grad students to help you know lead
various projects right and so there's
this whole like influx of people that I
mainly tasks to teach and so like they
stress testing every part of like what's
easy to learn what's easy to do
especially if someone writes really bad
art code like you don't crash the server
for everyone and like then I get phone
calls in middle of night and then you
know that's what I have deal with so how
do I make my life and their life easier
is really what I'm trying to talk about
and so the first thing that we've gone
over in my lab is we just moved
everything to doctor and I sort of wrote
this process so this was like about a
three year process where we moved from
VirtualBox that lxc containers and now
we're working with docker and that's
just really great because when someone
does mess something up and actually more
often than not it's really me messing
things up you know you can pick off the
docker container submit it back up and
you're exactly back to where you started
right you don't have to be worried about
like well what was that command that I
ran and if you want to if you actually
want that to be permanent you know you
put it into the doctor file script and
then that will be persisted and you've
recorded all your steps for that
particular snapshot and so this is
essentially what our labs infrastructure
looks like each one of these boxes is
roughly a docker container and so we
have we use for the most part Microsoft
are open but we also have a parallel one
that's running just our and the main
reason for that is Marcus off our open
comes with like the Intel
math kernal libraries pre-installed you
don't have to recompile are by yourself
so that's the reason the main reason why
we're doing it and then on top of that
we have our our student our Chinese
server and I have a special container
just for installing our packages that
I'll talk to you about but just like
that noble paper you can structure your
struck project templates to exactly how
you need rightly that was just a paper
to just make you think about it and so
I've adapted that to make it it's
something much simpler where you have a
data folder you have a source folder you
have an output folder and a readme and
everything is like in our project is
we're in our lab and so within data
source you know this is really
assembling to somewhere else on the
drive because you don't want to be
checking datasets into version control
and so that's the part that's
highlighted in orange and I've
essentially told my lab we just in here
create three folders original working
final where original that's where you
got the thing from you make those things
read-only you never touch that ever
again working are the things that like
this this computation took about three
hours I don't ever want to run this
again so I'll save it somewhere and then
final is like this is the data set that
I fully clean and I can fit my model
right away or I can fit a plot right
away you don't have to like redo an
analysis script or cleaning script you
can just base it off at one plot so
that's sort of what we've moved to in my
lab and so how do we install our
packages so we have this separate docker
container for our packages and so what
this lets me do is I can install in our
package for everyone because if you're
on a Linux system every single our
package is essentially compiled from
source and if you're doing install that
packages tidy verse that's gonna take
forever especially like the first day
when 20 people just got their new system
we're just sitting there waiting and
hopefully like our servers don't crash
and then here so the thing if you want
something install for everyone or we're
trying to install all of these packages
into one folder called our packages we
want that to be loaded into the order
that our looks for when you try to load
a data load a library so it's like a
path and if you want to do it for
everyone you look for a file call our
profile that's site it's so everyone has
a dot our profile in their home
directory but the our profile site does
it for everyone and so in here we pretty
much say hey we're changing lip path or
prepending so we're it's right there our
packages in front of everything else so
that gets loaded first
and then what we do for trying to
install a package in the arse of
packages container I say install
packages and then this allows me to say
like if I do need a system library for
example like SVG or JPEG or something I
can put it I can test everything out in
there and it slowly build up the whole
our stack from Microsoft our are open to
our studio at the SHINee and when that's
done we say docker push everything goes
to docker hub and then on our production
server we say dr. pol we get all the
brand new images down and then we turn
on and off containers as needed and load
them back up right so there's this no
recreate flag that I learned the hard
way that exists and you know if an
existing container is already running it
won't turn it off and turn it back on
because I've definitely ran this command
without it and I was like stop someone's
like compute that was like three hours
in I was like sorry so and then so
everything is running on our studio in
our lab and you know the open source
edition is great for individual use but
I'm slowly starting to realize it was
like trying to build the art pro stack
that everyone asks you just been working
so hard because now I'm like down this
rabbit hole of like alright there's so
there's engine X and like I have a
master's in public health why am I
looking at nginx which is like a web
server that helps you know do things so
we're in the process of exploring our
Studio Pro which should probably just
solve solve many of those problems but
at least for us because we're you know
trying to avoid paying for our Co Pro
everyone has their own our studio
container right so you know if you tank
a container you can just restart it and
I don't have to worry about it and that
helps really well with like if you have
if you're working with like groups to
manage permissions and stuff and then
for authorship in our lab we you know we
have overleaf and so one it's really
nice that everything overleaf and surely
tech both have real-time editing and
rendering and you can if you look under
the hood a little bit or click around
everything is
a git repository so you could also work
with it offline so we we use overleaf
our university provides us with a pro
account but I think that just limits
like how much how many figures you can
actually upload or something but because
we're also using docker you know you can
just run Sheryl a tech on your own
machine and they have a compose file
that will set up you know Sheryl a tech
MongoDB and Redis and you can actually
just log in on your own laptop or any
only machine play around with it and
then slowly figure out how to like
implement it in your own system and then
we have this thing where you know we you
know a lot of our coding like so back in
undergrad I did neuroscience and I was a
bench lab researcher and I've you know
I've gotten carpal tunnel and my thumb
and so we always had a lab notebook but
now all of our stuff is electronic so we
need to start documenting like processes
like especially when we have external
clients we want to be able to show them
like stuff and so right now our whole
system is built on Drupal because I
don't know why we picked Drupal for
WordPress but we're sort of we hired
someone new to help along and he knows
Python so we're now down this whole
Python Django wagtail stack which is a
content management system that we can
like start automating the whole like hey
when you click a new project it does all
of the backend stuff already because I
really didn't want to learn PHP because
that's what Drupal is so what are the
skills that you need get is really hard
and you know the shell or bash is the
glue that essentially will keep
everything together and so you know Greg
Wilson he's currently the head trainer
at data camp you know data cans been
mentioned many many times already and
they're essentially poke poaching the
community but he was the co-founder of
software carpentry and that's where I
got my beginnings and he wrote these two
really amazing courses because git and
bash are so essential they're totally
free on data camp for those if you want
to learn that on your own and so at the
same time I I teach for software
carpentry so they have all that free
material out there as well as that so
then how do you balance good practices
with you know just straight up getting
work done so
Titus Brown gave a talk at my University
and I have to like go meet him and
essentially like he said like just write
functions right you you don't need all
of this infrastructure to write a
function and you don't need you know
you'll read a lot about like hey
everything should be a package but like
you don't need to write a function and
then convert it into a package because
then updating the package is kind of
really annoying so you know as long as
you start writing functions and then you
think about moving it into a package as
you start using functions for your like
one project more and more you know then
you can start thinking about moving it
into a package right you don't need to
say like oh I'm writing this project
every function I need needs to go into a
package like don't do that because a lot
of those functions probably won't use
again right but at least it's a function
so you can reuse it internally if you
need to but really don't like write this
in your art code right like don't set a
working directory use our projects or
something there's even like a function
that you can make people copy and paste
in our studio so they actually open in
our studio project if they're if they're
not paying attention to where they are
there's two other really amazing
packages one is called here and our
project route and essentially it will
find things for you within like a
project hierarchy so you really
shouldn't have to find set working
directory right so like I have a folder
called functions it's in this tiny
folder and I can just say here just go
find me this it's in there shiny and
there's a thing called functions just
give me a path and then I can source the
whole thing for you so you don't even
need to write like this interactive
thing which is what I used to do all the
time and then here is just a higher
level interface for our project route
and then saving things you know you can
always save things to CSV I used to
always say hey use the base save and
load function but I actually more
recently found out that base also has
the save RDS and read RDS functions
which is actually a lot better because
what happens when you save something
when you load it back up those variables
whatever state they were in come up into
your environment so if you had another
data frame named EF and you loaded
something you just over wrote something
and that's not good so save and load so
read RDS actually lets you assign it
back to a variable of your choice so
you're not just overwriting random
things in your environment without no
and then secrets so how do we deal with
like random passwords we don't
especially don't want to put it into get
so there's this get pass function that's
pretty generic it can call it the our
Studio API to ask you for a question if
you're in our studio it'll prompt you in
the command line if you're running
scripts in the command line and then
there's the secrets library so in here
there's you know they get passed from
there but in get secret the secret
library it can use the SSH key to
encrypt other things so in my lab we use
this to encrypt our passwords so you
don't have to constantly put in username
and password when you're getting data
out of a database and that's also really
useful when you start knitting documents
because when you click knit there's no
actual way to put in user input or your
hard coding your username and password
and their note there's no reason why
like students should have my password
because they will have sudo root access
to everything so so packages you know
there is all that so that is an example
of something that we put into a package
ourselves called SLR I haven't moved it
up the crane yet but there's a great
free book about packages that you can
read as well and then I gave a talk
about testing and then in the end I want
to talk about cookbook so our markdown
is really really powerful when I've
given two talks about them and there is
this free reference called the our
graphics cookbook and there's also a
book accompanied with it but from the
Python world in 2015 they were having
this problem of like coming up with a
better color map right and so there's
this color map called Firdous that they
made because matlab made a color map
called perilla and they didn't allow
anyone to use it today really okay let's
create a room and so virtus if you're
from the Python world it's named that
first snake if you don't like Python
it's a fish if you're really attached to
MATLAB
it's named after bird so for this this
is what virtus looks like and it's an
actual art package that's being used for
your color maps and this is a really
good color map because it's it can print
in grayscale you can its colorblind
friendly and you know Noam Ross who is
one of our speakers you know put this
together for the art community and one
thing I want to talk about is like hey
there's color maps start thinking about
you know specific color maps
for yourself for specific variables so
when you're working as a group you don't
have to you know think too much about
what you're looking at and there was a
great talk from the Python community as
well about how an oceanographer has
specific color maps that they put
together and if you really can't be
bothered you know there's the color
Brewer which I use to just help you pick
really good color maps so you can call
it you can check off like if it's
colorblind save or print friendly and
you can get like a nice color map out of
it for yourself as well and then other
things you know make cookbooks as needed
make your own flight rules there's a
really good flight rule repository about
like how you can use git without you
know just starting over and we cloning
things and then so why am I telling all
of this well from Greg Wilson our planet
needs our help and we need good science
to fix it so thanks everyone again thank
you
you